morning elon musk wants to expand his
company's footprint in las vegas and he
has the city of las vegas on board
last night his boring company presented
plans to stretch the underground people
mover and this time
to downtown las vegas the proposal put
to the city's planning commission
tunnels would go down las vegas
boulevard across ogden and then back up
along main street and one of the first
stops there
the new circle resort we're very excited
and happy this is finally coming to
fruition and we're
fully in support of of uh being part of
this and having a loop come
right at our front door and we're going
to be happy to put in hopefully one of
the first stations
right in our garage mahal to help
hopefully get people directly from the
airport or from the strip to the game to
downtown las vegas
so i think it's a great thing for
downtown derrick stevens is a more
reserved brother craig there speaking on
behalf of circa
the planning commission did approve
these plans and that means the las vegas
city council will have a chance to cast
their vote in december
musk's company also wants to expand the
people movers to the allegiance stadium
and mccarran airport the first part of
the people mover under the convention
center
should open in january very exciting
alex oh it's so cool and the garage
mahal
coming up